here's a pizza proof that 0.9 repeating
is equal to one start with a nine-sided
Pizza
scale the pizza down to one tenth of its
size in the center you can then create
nine equal slices between these two
shapes
this area will be nine over ten of the
original pizza but we can now repeat the
process scale this down and then create
nine more equal slices since it's scaled
down by one-tenth these will be nine
over ten squared of the original areas
scale it down again and repeat the
process and this will be 9 over 10 to
the power of three of The Original Pizza
if we keep iterating this process
infinitely many times we'll of course
slice up the entire pizza into some
slice so this will all be equal to one
now point nine repeating by definition
is the sum of this geometric series and
that is equal to one and therefore 0.9
repeating is equal to one